boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sakyan we
are on site in Sioux Falls South Dakota
now very excited to be sitting down with
Dr Elizabeth Hague we are going to be
talking about mastering the MCAT and I'm
super excited thank you for joining us
thanks for inviting me to the show and
we have a lot to discuss and there's so
much Nuance to this but then there's
also a cool background that we're
dealing with with Elizabeth's she's an
associate professor of biology at
Northwestern College in Iowa in Orange
City Iowa and also a PhD at Northwestern
University in Chicago prior to that in
biology and developmental biology yep
developmental biology
and and so in the last four years as the
project manager at adapt preparation for
the MCAT and that is extremely important
because so many people want to pursue
being a doctor and where how do we
leverage the right sort of Technologies
to help people become doctors make it
of our people that have lower
socioeconomic status how do they
absolutely enter into becoming a doctor
how do we make it more accessible with
the degrees of freedom enabling people
to do what they want with their with
their time in their lives and then also
with the transition in 2015 to the
difference with adding psych and soch
and the cars critical analysis and
reasoning skills skills I'm impressed so
we got yeah thank you we got we got we
got a lot of talk about very excited so
let's start with let's start with you
um let's talk about you know how did you
become so fascinated with Biology who
were you when you were younger and how
did this sort of come up yeah okay this
yeah
um you know I think I liked I liked
School overall so I I loved my French
classes so growing up in Canada we
learned French I went to a private
school early on and so that's kind of
weird that I didn't go into more with
that but I didn't see the Practical side
of things which sounds maybe kind of
silly but
um loved history classes as well I think
in high school I got the history award
didn't get the biology award I got the
history award
um it's cool but there was something
achievement based in science that really
kind of fed my inner Joy if you will and
so when it came time to choosing a
profession someday you know I thought oh
maybe I'll be a doctor a medical doctor
when I'm I'm done with college so I went
into college thinking I would be pre-med
um yeah and and that kind of spurred me
on into a biology track took a totally
different curve than pre-med for myself
personally but yeah yeah now you get to
help thousands of kids around the world
yeah yeah that's my goal yes yes with
becoming uh doctors now and I and I
would like to clarify is the is is and
we can get more into this later but then
is adapt prep is it also looking to
figure out how to help people around the
world outside yeah that's a good
question so the MCAT varies
um can the Canadian MCAT and the
American MCAT very similar but you go to
Australia or you go to Europe and you're
going to get just those slightly
different variety of the MCAT I think
there's one of theirs is called the
maybe the GMAT even
um but yeah absolutely would love to
help globally and and especially
individuals who
um you know don't have that money to pay
for some of the bigger companies I'll
call them the big box stores for MCAT
prep materials and being able to afford
that and to get the Competitive Edge
that way for those people who can't
afford that I would love to offer them
this tool that of course in my opinion
which might be biased but in my opinion
is going to give just as much if not
more quality
software to help them prepare for the
MCAT I want to give them access to this
tool yeah yeah yeah this is I want I'm
excited to talk about the the global
side of this in the socioeconomic side
of this soon and further into the
conversation it's interesting that you
you know when we first met and shout out
to Garrett thanks for introducing us
um yes huge shout out now now what's the
you know when we first met you said that
you were most fascinated with teaching
and that you loved when when the
students would learn and we started
talking about like the difference
between having knowledge just you know
gained inside of you versus being able
to actually teach other people that
knowledge in relatable ways and get
their perspective augmented that's like
really important intelligence to have
yeah so tell us about that because now
it's been 12 years for you professing
yeah yep you know
even I know before when we were chatting
about it I didn't so much mention this
yet but
there's always been this teaching vibe
in me so the way that I afforded to go
to college was to be a lifeguard and a
swimming lesson teacher so that's that's
how I earned my shekels for that and so
there was always this kind of teaching
thread there and then in graduate school
um I mean I got a 4.0 in graduate school
but my passion wasn't so much in
acquiring the knowledge I mean I I
enjoyed that the achiever in me loved it
but
my my joy was most abundant when I was a
ta a teaching assistant in graduate
school and so listening to that in me is
is really what made me decide okay yeah
I could be a research professor
but my joy comes from teaching others so
I'm going to pursue more of a teaching
professing role versus a research role
and also this this ability to realize
yeah you can be really really smart
but if you can't translate that to
others if you can't share your
intelligence
oh it in my opinion it decreases the
value a little bit if if your your
knowledge isn't transferable
definitely it loses some some value yeah
not to say that it's not valuable but
for me the most value in my knowledge
comes from sharing it with others I
guess that's one way to put it yeah
there's a a couple things there
um the sort of first thing you touched
on was this uh the the translational
like the application of research uh to
the world and that's becoming more and
more critical through people that we
interview that are scientists they're
like thirsty to have and that's awesome
so important yeah right and I mean
there's that problem solving sorry to
cut you off I want to hear what you have
to say about this yeah that that problem
solving and that investigation is
fascinating I I'm not saying that I
don't value that but my passion wasn't
there I think my passion I became the
most alive when I was teaching others
transferring that knowledge
um but yeah research is fascinating
there was I don't know if you saw my
Facebook page there was just a case of a
girl who or a young woman who was able
to regain sight because of gene therapy
and so there's so many useful
science projects going on right now that
it's it's pretty fascinating to watch
and so my hope is yeah I probably won't
ever well I won't create say a research
project that will solve someone's you
know medical issues but maybe I can play
a part by
helping people from a from a greater
array from a more diverse population
to cultivate their passion to pursue
medicine some of them might even pursue
research maybe MD PhD type students as
well and and bring them to the table
that normally wouldn't come to the table
and and help them transfer their
knowledge in ways that would be useful
to a greater population yeah yeah I love
thinking about what different cultures
from around the world will bring to the
global Collective knowledge base once
they have the full potential to bring
their like their culture and Heritage
principles to specific fields that are
emerging
um so yeah so that translational was
super important that you brought up and
then within this whole idea of of of
intelligence because we've now had
this in this is just such a blessing
that we after these billions of years of
evolution have this what's a pinnacle
potentially of humans now taking
stewardship of this planet sure and so
now it's become what is that
intelligence is that intelligence if
it's just baked within you then okay but
really being able to pass it on in
relatable ways to augment other people's
perspectives is so valuable to to the
next Generations to have them be better
stewards and whatnot so I'm really happy
that we've that we chatted specifically
about that as well
um I want to know because this is really
important we like asking this to people
that are professing
um because when there's so much to gain
from your experience over a dozen years
of like what have been some of these key
takeaways for you with teaching to
students that that you think would be
really important to teach about right
now um
professors or to teach about oh that's a
good question yeah people watching um I
would like to hear both
um yeah to just to normal like audience
of like this is just this is what's been
really interesting about
um about being a professor but also to
potentially like yeah what can help
other people become better teachers as
well sure yeah yeah
a great question um and I think not
enough people ask that question you know
as as a noob when I was a new professor
I tried to do a lot of reading of what
does make a great professor and there's
not a ton out there in fact one of the
first books I I read or one of the first
articles I read talked about well the
really good teachers are so busy
teaching that they're not writing
articles about being good teachers oh
that's interesting yeah so it's awesome
to have someone like you asking these
questions now
for for me personally what I've seen is
if you anchor new knowledge to current
knowledge that's the best way you're
gonna retain it and and when I'm when
I'm saying that that's more like factual
knowledge type of stuff it's not so much
thinking out of the box being a creative
you know new knowledge developer it's
more okay how do you learn what's
already out there and with that with my
students anyways if you anchor it to
something they already know it's going
to make it more I don't know what's more
connectable
um the the example that pops into my
head every year for microbiology that I
teach we learn about the Lac operon I'm
going all science geeky on you so what
is that again yeah yeah so the the Lac
operon it's a series of genes within
bacteria that help them process lactose
as an energy source and so in our
microbiology class we look at that Lac
operon to say how does a cell something
as simple as a bacteria cell know when
to turn certain genes on and off and I
equated that to me wanting a Jeep
someday and what the limiting factors
are and what the promoting factors are
in me attaining this Jeep someday and so
it would be well incurring bills would
be a limiting factor if I spend money on
other things
um yeah that would limit things like
that you know this is usually like a 20
30 minute class so I won't I won't go
too much but I see where you're going
okay so it's in order for the biological
process to commence you need certain
certain things present in the
environment to make Gene transcription
happen yep yeah yeah and seriously yeah
and that would be the same thing with
you wanting to get a car which is very
relatable example for students who are
are wanting to earn a vehicle or
whatever it may be yeah yeah or we can
talk about enzymes and dating services
so oh that's so cool see this is like
this is good science communication
practice Yeah Yeah because they can
relate to or they understand
okay here are these two people that out
in society they might come together and
form this product of a couple
but if there's a dating service and they
both are attracted to that dating
service it's going to be more likely
that they find each other and this and
again this is right up the alley of you
know 18 to 21 year olds and how does
that relate to enzymes so how that
relates to enzymes is that you know
there's certain substrates or chemicals
that can come together and
um form a different product
but the enzyme's presence is going to
speed that reaction it's going to make
it more likely that those two substrates
come together catalyzing agents like the
app is a catalyzing yeah like the dating
app would be a catalyzing agent and that
they're like oh yeah we get that we get
that that makes sense interesting yeah I
love these relatable science
Communications they're so good yeah
they're so good there's so many of them
okay so that's a huge principle in
teaching and professing is making things
relatable to like to the generation
where they're at currently yeah and that
gets tough right
um so when I first started teaching at
the college level I was only 26. and I
was more in that time frame with those
students and now as I approach my 40s
sometimes it's like oh I think this is
really cool and my students are kind of
like hmm yeah you know well if you are
you because our grade is in your hands
um so to stay on top of that as well yes
is kind of a cool thing so then it's
interesting that a professor would then
need to be keeping up with the newest
technology Trends and what the
Collegiate students are using in order
to try and make the science relatable at
the moment in time yeah yep yep like
what what kind of things
Intrigue them you know right now I've
got a 13 year old son and he loves
fortnite yeah and so when he's a college
student someday and I'm I'm hoping my
observations of fortnight are gonna you
know come come to value for me in some
kind of connection yeah
so let's let's talk about MCAT sure
because you know you were you taught me
about this earlier and it was really
interesting learning about this from you
that in so first of all there's the a a
m c the association of American medical
colleges yeah and they make them Cat
every year yep okay and then that and
that's for just the United States and
there's one for and and for Canada as
well all yeah and then there's
differences for once in Europe or
Australia or China Asia Middle East
whatever people of different that's my
understanding entrances yeah yeah but
they kind of follow some similar
scientific principles of biology
chemistry physics yeah so okay now now
this is what got interesting is in 2015
there was this additional of cars so
then a quarter of the test became cars
which is again critical critical
analysis and reasoning skills reasoning
skills and then
um which is really important because
that's basically like parsing
information and taking key takeaways
from it and
than psychology and sociology became a
quarter of it and then the other quarter
is the biology chemistry physics stuff
but the other half is that yeah so
so then that gave adapt prep now where
European at that gave adapt prep kind of
it's a new it's a an ability to kind of
come in there and say oh well now that
there's this new addition we can come in
there and and provide this assisted the
software that assists with learning
that is two hundred dollars versus like
you were pointing at earlier the fifteen
hundred dollar plus course yeah you got
it yeah so now yeah tell us about like
the the the this MCAT prep and you know
your tag is you know mastering the MCAT
which is you know it's beautiful and
it's again it's low cost but you provide
more than the high cost so it's like
it's hard to you know how do you get
people yeah how do you well and trust is
such a big thing I think too like how
how do you get people to believe hey
this is a quality product even though it
may not have that super big price tag of
some of these other big box
um stores if you will and you know
hopefully with time and students talking
to other students to say hey this really
does work that's how it's going to
propagate among pre-med students and you
know I've even seen
um a couple there there's a couple
schools that we have arrangements with I
won't name drop just for you know I
don't know if it's legality issues or
whatnot but to hear back from them yeah
our MCAT scores are increasing
using this software
and it's pretty cool that's awesome to
hear yeah that's awesome yeah so it's
it's having an impact yeah
um and and that brings me joy too
because there's nothing worse than doing
something yeah for me anyways than doing
something that has no value right
um yeah
but so the premise of all of this is
that students are paying for their
undergraduate or classes right they're
taking the physics class they're taking
the chemistry classes the biochemistry
classes and yet there's this mindset out
there and I don't know if it's like a
you know a marketing thing that has
happened over the years where oh yeah
you did all these college classes but
now you have to take this other course
and relearn everything
and I could see with with some of my
colleagues they're like no we we do a
good job in the classroom you shouldn't
have to relearn everything and I I would
agree with them on that sense to kind of
cultivate this idea of you don't have to
relearn everything because that's not
the best use of your time now what is
time no I'm just kidding yeah yeah no
just asking
we won't go there but
um
you know the the best use of their time
is having had these college courses or
these university courses and then
instead of relearning everything figure
out what you learned well and figure out
maybe what you didn't learn well maybe
you know maybe it was because you didn't
cover that in some of your classes or
maybe you didn't learn it as well as you
thought or retained it as well as you
thought and so that's where adapt prep
comes in and as a student takes practice
exams they can kind of assess did I
learn things well enough
um where where am I weak or where did I
learn things incorrectly right yeah
because you don't you don't know that
you don't know something until you get
it wrong yeah yeah and so that's that's
where this comes alongside and then
instead of you know instead of reading
this textbook and that you already know
80 of you want to focus on that 20 that
you don't know so well and and that's
where you're going to get the biggest
bang for your buck as far as investing
time into MCAT preparations is review
that 20 percent or learn that 20 because
you already know this why why keep going
over that yeah but that's where people
are comfortable right I mean I do it all
the time too it's it's I'm going to
teach stuff in my classroom and put
stuff on my syllabus that I'm really
confident I know things about and as as
someone prepping for the MCAT you can't
stay in your favorite areas totally
because you're going to get this stuff
on the test too yeah yeah that's that's
a that's a very valuable principle for
life in general is that Pareto Principle
of that especially for something like an
MCAT that there you you have this sort
of like 80 percent understanding of
certain materials and that it feels good
and then this other 20 you basically
need to focus eighty percent of your
time on the 20 of the material you don't
know and then slowly work your way into
having a more well rounded and so this
is like the adaptable MCAT where you're
you're in a certain field of study like
biology and you may not know certain
things so you're adapting the questions
to become more and more difficult with
them over time absolutely yeah I'm glad
you brought that up so yeah it's part of
the basis of the software then you take
a so there's four sections on the MCAT
and you could start out just working on
one section if you wanted to you take a
full-length exam which is about 90
minutes the MCAT in total is about a
seven and a half hour exam so it's it's
pretty crazy but it's so crazy yeah
um so you can take you can take a
full-length exam and and we start you
off relatively easy and that's that's
something I I still kind of question of
maybe we need to start people off really
difficult but our scale of earned level
so scale of difficulty is is one to ten
and we give students an exam starting
off at level three and based on how they
do on that first exam the next exam they
take will either be more challenging or
yeah less difficult
that way we can meet the student where
they're at and then help them
go to where they need to be yeah yeah
and so that the software is going to
adapt according to that level of
difficulty for them yeah yeah that that
that process of adapting is it's a
closed-loop feedback system and that
seems to be a huge aspect of
um of of the future in terms of
technology and adaptability of of in
information dissemination and knowledge
gaining slowly building up over time
yeah so how does this is a big database
this is like 1200 or so questions the
cars the cars section has 1200 questions
in it and then we have about 1200 in the
chemistry biochemistry section or
chemistry physics biochemistry and then
a thousand each in biology biochemistry
and psyc and social and we're constantly
working on so one of my rules
um as project I'm project manager so
trying to coordinate and disseminate
that this that we exist but my other
rule is a Content writer so we're
constantly adding content to the
question bank which is kind of fun it
keeps me learning so yeah yeah there's
new new and new and more new yep to
continue adding and making the questions
non-biased and non-leading and all sort
of kind of stuff yeah and and there's
definitely a language of how aamc writes
their questions on the MCAT that
sometimes you know someone who's writing
for aamc may not take as academic
approach as maybe I would and so that's
been great for my own teaching
experience to realize there's different
ways to get at whether this person has
this knowledge and I might ask a
question a certain way because that's
been my training whereas somebody else
with slightly different training will
ask you know it's getting to the same
end point but with a different question
so so for me for me not only am I
working on developing this software
content but I'm also learning how to be
a better teacher at the same time which
is pretty cool
that was a lot of babbling I love that I
love that right there that was so good
because it's so true is that that is a
good way to become a better at whatever
you're doing in life is to be looking at
the tip of the industry or The Cutting
Edge of the industry and then bringing
it into the dissemination the best ways
of disseminating and that is again
that's like storytelling that's you know
you have to decide on whether something
is going to be a multiple choice or a
short answer or a long answer
written that's all very difficult and
that's like life skills right so it's
it's beyond just the MCAT it's these are
these are skills that these individuals
will take into the rest of their life of
okay I've got this knowledge but in the
classroom setting I'm I'm being asked
the question in this way in the medical
setting I'm probably going to be it
asked in a different way but still
needing that knowledge so can I decipher
the way
or can I even anticipate the way I'm
being asked or even assess hey you're
asking that different than when I was
tested on it do I still know what you're
talking about and get this answer yeah
because there's like there's a big
difference between knowing an answer to
a question versus seeing the question
and answer in a real life scenario and
then needing to add some sort of
Knowledge from another domain to it or
you know that's kind of the critical
analysis and reasoning that you have to
do to make a decision yep yeah you know
you see this piece of
um writing that might not even be well
probably it won't be from your field of
expertise right it'll be from dance or
history or or whatnot and you have to
reason within the text and also reason
beyond the text yeah and we want doctors
to do that right totally because you're
not going to have the typical textbook
patient every time exactly and if you if
if you have that patient or if I'm the
patient and you know know my doctor's
like oh well you don't check all the
boxes like in my textbook for this
I don't I don't want kind of doctor I
want someone who can okay this and this
so maybe this yeah
it's it's at times there's a protocol
and then at times it's figuring out how
to potentially do things off protocol
that are actually much better for the
scenario at hand and you want to be
agile but also be Beyond protocol as
needed as well so it's kind of like
adaptability adaptability yeah we had it
we had a Dr Robert lustig on our show
and he's a pediatric endocrinologist and
so when we're when we were talking to
him he was he was very upset at how the
Physicians are now having this instead
of doing eye to eye with patient it's
like I on computer screen doing
electronic medical record right while
yeah instead of the bonding yeah and so
I'm curious to hear what your
perspective is there and like what's
going on with the MCAT related to
electronic medical records and stuff
yeah that's a good question
um so a couple of things there
fortunately there's been some problem
solving I think so there's been
entrepreneurs that have come in and
developed what's called a medical scribe
so there's several different companies
across the U.S yeah that's what I told
him by the way I was like we're yeah
we're going to just really quickly be
able to enter in the audio into text and
fill in the uh sure or that too yeah
yeah
um so one company that I'll give a shout
out to M modal and modal is one of the
Scribe companies um I think there's
another one scribe scribe America or
something
um where oftentimes there's there's
students who will take a year off
between undergrad and medical school or
a couple years off and there'll be a
medical scribe and what they do is
they're the ones at the computer for
these Physicians now most of the
hospitals that have medical scribes are
typically the bigger hospitals they're
you're not probably going to see a
scribe at a rural hospital but I think
that's that's starting to solve that
issue because I would agree if you're
not looking at that person you're you
you're you're losing a ton of
communication yeah yeah emotional
relatability
um non-verbal cues nonverbal cues yeah
all this kind of stuff and then yeah and
then it's interesting so then these
companies that you're listing that are
doing the Scribe that they're there's
they're doing audio to text and then you
have to look at the text afterward is
that what they're doing no what they're
actually doing is they're training
individuals to sit in the hospital or
the clinical room with the doctor and
parse for the key points write them down
oh there's something they're doing this
yes oh interesting yeah oh oh cool so so
then the physician is having the
one-on-one and the Scribe is filling in
the health record you got it oh that's
that's very interesting yeah so that
that that's kind of one of those things
where someone had a great idea that's a
good solution yeah that's a good
solution I also think that soon we'll be
able to go directly from audio to text
and have that text input into the health
records so it would be like a parser for
the for the audio to text which is
basically what the scribers do yeah
they're the parser yeah yep and then the
doctor can go back and make sure and
look at it afterwards to see okay did
you really translate what I was saying
and then there's always this other I
mean there's so many
facets to to being in a in a clinical
setting with a patient because then you
wonder what's going to happen with
insurance and liability cases right it's
like well we've got your audio right
here you know it's not going to scare
people away from the healthcare
profession I don't know oh yeah that's
another that's a whole other tangent
right yeah oh man that's a really
interesting point though is that we're
approaching the end of privacy in many
ways and so if I if that is a HIPAA
compliant medical
safe Zone and yeah if that audio is now
being leaked into wherever else right
about my yeah or or does it make and so
not only HIPAA kind of privacy issues
but does that make the physician even
more
um what's the word I'm looking for
cautious
in their treatments or in their
diagnosis because oh my goodness is this
going to come back and haunt me whoa
yeah so there's a lot of there's a lot
of things to think about it becomes on
on so much pressure they're on a lot of
pressure and everything becomes
um described everything becomes written
down what the so everything's being
analyzed on what they're recommending
how they're recommending it and what
dosages
um to What patients to what Etc like you
know the which Protocols are they
following For What It's Like that's
starting to be interesting so you see it
sorry you see a good side to that right
because totally as a patient I'm like oh
yeah that's going to make me feel more
confident because if this doctor screws
up I've got record of it
um that's right and and maybe hopefully
you know going the more optimistic route
this is going to allow or enable
Physicians to be more accountable right
yeah because it's like I better be on my
game every time because it's getting
recorded whereas if it's not can I you
know can I become a little less cautious
we're seeing that exact same thing
happening with police officers now
because
cameras yeah so that's true that you
can't
um yeah can't potentially be overly
aggressive uh and or hurting people that
are not committing crimes and whatnot
and all this different type of stuff but
shout out to all the good police
officers and Physicians Physicians yeah
that are that are keeping good care of
humanity
um I want to also follow up on that
optimistic route with Physicians and AIS
uh because I have a I have a strong
feeling as well that potentially where
we could go with the end of privacy
could be a very good place with
transparency that what about your
Biometrics really needs to be needs to
stay hidden from the rest of humanity
because as long as all of these nodes of
individuals that have all their
Biometrics are opened
um the data side no data siloing is
great then we can have the best possible
ways of treating each other and making
sure we stay in the best health possible
and also with Physicians on the their
side is that them having total
transparency with the way that they're
prescribing certain remedies and whatnot
and making diagnoses can then
be more easily
data can be analyzed on those things and
then we can see who's doing the best why
they're doing the best how we can help
other people do it better actually yeah
there's like more data database
treatment like okay the data really does
show
that this is this is happening well have
you watched the movie Gattaca yeah yeah
so it's starting to really sound like
we're approaching this Gattaca total
reality yeah um especially with Gene
sequencing and things like that and so
while we have these amazing tools that
we're developing I think it's always a
good idea to take a step back once in a
while and say okay yeah this we're
developing this to be used for good
but what's the bad that could be a
consequence of this and just to be
careful about that and then how do we
ensure that that bad doesn't come to
fruition that's right yeah and so going
back to the MCAT that's where I'm
excited that in 2015 there's now this
psychology and sociology aspect to the
MCAT because it's it's requiring pre-med
students to have some background in
psychology and sociology you know they
didn't necessarily have to have any
psych or so going into med school years
ago but really that's that's a big part
of being a physician is being able to
understand beyond the physical to be
being able to understand the psychology
that we maybe you know don't necessarily
have those litmus tests for yeah that's
a huge addition in 2015. absolutely I'm
so happy that it did happen yeah
um and then the cars yes
those additions were huge you when you
taught me about them I was like whoa
that's great like that's a huge
advancement in the right direction yeah
and we'll see I mean I think there may
be another one of those
um advancements that happening to the
MCAT in the next couple of years with
artificial intelligence yeah I don't
know we don't know interesting yeah and
then we'll have Physicians learning
better about how machines learned and
how machines can help with the medical
processes right right well and that's
kind of what our software does in a in a
way to the AI That's built into our
software it's you know the students are
hopefully learning from our software but
the software is also learning based on
their performance yes with our questions
and adapting the question Bank to the
user which is yep pretty cool that's and
that's one of the most crucial aspects
about these close Loop adaptive
technology platforms that that exist
that is I think catalyzing much more
success in in the dissemination of these
complex sciences and experiences to
people that can go out and become their
best in the fields yeah now let's talk a
bit on SCS and socioeconomic status
because this is so crucial we we were
we're democratizing the cost of these
products down down down down which is
enabling more and more people to pursue
I hope so with economic freedom yeah
yeah this is great because you're down
at 200 now that's the cost yep so
fortunately
um this would be my boss the the owner
of adapt prep MCAT
um
he's very on board with this philosophy
of hey not only are we going to help
students do well in the MCAT we're also
going to help students who may be in a
lower socio-economic class be able to
afford this Competitive Edge that some
other individuals get yeah yeah I don't
know where I was going with that but I'm
I'm happy that that is like that has to
be baked into the morals and ethics of
the organization in order for other
people to to actually reap the fruits of
of there's like there's so much research
that points to the more and more that
the investment of financial rewards go
into production into democratization
into making more economic degrees of
freedom for other people that the better
a society is and that the more that it
goes into like hoarding and uh and
whatnot the worse the society gets yeah
so it's kind of like
it's interesting that it's it's always
been like that history has always been
showing that principle and so
um to have it baked into your morals and
ethics that that is such a crucial
investing back into the production to
make it more available to more people
absolutely yeah yeah well and I think
you know while while this is just a
microcosm of
the big picture right we're helping
students prep for the MCAT but maybe so
this is like dreaming big right maybe
we're also having an impact on health
care as a whole
because if we can help or enable more
students from a diverse background
show that or demonstrate that they are
ready for med school and that they're
they're fully capable for and they've
got that high MCAT score now get them
into health care that diversity is going
to improve health care yeah we were
talking about that at the beginning as
well as that the more of the cultural
and Heritage that comes from around the
world to solve some of these challenging
problems the more of these different
philosophies and techniques that we can
explore and pursue to actually come to
solutions to the pressing problems yeah
and there's there's some great books out
there the one that comes to mind and I'm
kicking myself because I can't remember
the author but it was the spirit catches
the spirit catches you and you fall down
or the spirit catches me and have you
have you heard of that I don't think so
um it's it's a fascinating book I used
to have my anatomy and physiology
students read it and because it brings
in all these different facets from
treating an individual
and it tells the Real the true story of
this Hmong Refugee family out in
California and how they were they had an
epileptic daughter and she went to
receive medical treatment for her
seizures and and the American Medical
approach was so different than the the
cultural heritage in treating this
individual you know culturally in the
Hmong population from my understanding
anyways is that at the time epileptic
individuals were were seen or are seen
as Shaman you know very very wise and
something spiritually gifted and so you
don't necessarily want to end the
seizures whereas from an American
Medical perspective it's like no you
have to be on all these different
medications let's you know this is our
goal and so to see these two dare I say
opposite kind of polar approaches and
how they butted heads yeah
um I'm glad you brought that up yeah
it's fascinating yeah that's the that's
the interdisciplinary understanding of
medicine yep yeah yeah and then a social
worker comes into that picture
um and and and really you know she could
see it was an American social worker so
she could see the perspective the
cultural perspective of the American
Medical
um professionals but then she got to
know these people themselves
um and it ended up being yeah it's a
fascinating story I won't ruin the the
end of it you should ruin then ruin ruin
the end of it and you should teach us
the end because so many people won't
read it okay watch it and so that's why
I always say it's not even ruining it's
sharing so that people can kind of
shortcut if they if they need if they
need to yeah well I mean
so it ended up being that this
unfortunate I shouldn't say fortunately
unfortunately this woman who was or this
girl who was struggling with seizures
had a grand mal seizure so so one that
put her into a vegetative state
and so now the medical professionals
there's not much more they can do yeah
and the family's approach was
so optimal that this girl lived into I
think she was like 21 22 maybe even
older when she passed away and the
medical professionals were just blown
away by that because a typical patient
of theirs that had that same experience
just
lacks in the follow-up care from their
family members or from the you know
maybe the convalescence home that they
get put into or I guess it wouldn't be
convalescence at that point but
um that This Woman's life was as long as
it was because of the quality of care
that her family gave her and so and you
know when she was still struggling with
seizures
the hospital professionals were like no
you guys are excuse my language idiots
what are you doing
um but they were caring for their
daughter as best as they knew how yeah
and so
um yeah seeing you read this book and at
one point you're ticked off at the
medical professionals and at the other
point you're ticked off at the you know
the family and then you're you're ticked
off at the infrastructure that is child
protective services because they ended
up taking this kid away from her parents
and that's when she had her biggest
seizure actually and so there's it's
it's just this conglomeration of real
life messiness yeah yeah
the interdisciplinary approach and
that's something interesting for
Physicians as well that are going
through the process of inspiring medical
students to become doctors because what
and even for existing doctors existing
professors existing students across
basically any discipline is that having
a multi-disciplinary approach to
whatever we are practicing it opens our
perspective to adding in some of the oh
well what is the culture this culture
that is literally present for me how do
they feel about what's going on right
now or or what does someone of high or
low SES or this religion or that
religion or this can color that skin
color why do those things matter in in
building out a complex nuanced
perspective on every single issue around
us
I'm glad you brought up that
interdisciplinary because that's so
important to
especially as you go to attempt to
master the MCAT what is so important is
again that's why you added the psych and
social that's why you're adding critical
reasoning and Analysis skills yeah
because you don't
you don't want a doctor well in my
opinion anyways you don't want a doctor
that absolutely I mean to some extent
follows the protocol to a t because that
protocol isn't going to fit every
individual so we really want to recruit
people to the profession who who know
the protocol
but who are you know throw out
adaptability again right who are
adaptable enough that they can adapt to
the situation they can adapt to that
person going back to you know the whole
medical records and scribing and stuff
like that that that doctor really needs
to be in tune with who's in front of
them in order to to fully grasp how to
treat them yeah yeah well that's
interesting maybe in the future on the
on mastering the MCAT there will be a
portion of like emotional intelligence
where they'll have to like look at the
different complex facial expressions
sure well it's funny you say that
because in the last two years and I
don't know enough about this realm
um to to speak maybe adequately about it
but there's a new test that health
profession schools are requiring as part
of their admittance test I think it's
called Caspa first time I heard of it I
thought Casper
no maybe it is Casper actually Casper
might be the the centralized application
service for physicians assistant so all
these acronyms in my head yeah yeah so
Casper is this
um kind of this moral and ethical type
test for individuals who are applying to
PA school or I don't couple Med schools
that I know my students have applied to
have used it as well so they already are
getting into that of are you ethical
um how and and again what does ethical
mean right yeah because there's no
protocol for that there's there's a lot
of different opinions on what is an
ethical decision yeah but
our society is trying to create tests
that will measure that and again that's
where diversity is going to be so
critical because you need that diverse
input of what is ethical yeah yeah whoa
yeah maybe entering like more like
emotional intelligence and ethical
intelligences in the decision making I
love hearing that because that's
that creeping into our political and
economic and scientific infrastructures
is critical absolutely to Prosperity but
again it all depends on who's defining
yeah what's ethical yeah yeah um I think
in a very
um a strong collective intelligence
there is super important
um
so what else you know closing out what
else should we know about mastering the
MCAT that maybe that you've learned that
adapt prep is providing like what else
is really important that we may not have
touched on hmm
much in so many different situations I
always forget what I've shared and what
I haven't but
um you know earlier when I mentioned the
80 versus 20 so really learning about
yourself to say where do I need to put
the effort in yeah
um kind of a side note tangent when I
first started with adapt prep MCAT I was
I was still wearing my professor hat a
lot more I actually wasn't even employed
by adapt prep MCAT I did a survey of my
students and also
um several hundred students throughout
the United States and ask them different
questions like when do you know you're
ready for the MCAT and it blew me away
because here are these people that are
supposedly being trained as scientists
and their answer was the majority of
them I know I'm ready for the MCAT when
I feel ready
and like that just blew me away because
I'm like you guys are supposed you know
you've got some scientific training here
and you're assessing whether you're
ready for the MCAT Based On A Feeling
yeah
um
and so in that sense this mastering the
MCAT with adapt prep with the software
we're we're developing and continue to
develop
I'm I'm hoping it's a confidence booster
and it's kind of a data collector right
it's I'm ready for the MCAT when I score
this high on the practices exactly
that's a good scientific reasoning and
that's like yeah that's like if you come
in really hot like you know a lot about
the subjects then great you may only
need to study a hundred hours and you'll
be ready but if you don't and you need
more practice you may study 400 hours
but then you're going to be at the same
level of Readiness as the person that
only studied a hundred dollars and it
doesn't mean you're going to be any less
of a doctor totally it's just you need
to invest some more resources before
you're ready for that next step exactly
um very interesting and now that for me
that does kind of segue into what some
of these other companies are doing that
I've seen
um from my perspective you'll take one
of their practice exams and your result
will score really low
um because they're trying to recruit you
to buy their software and their prep
materials right it's like oh yeah you
suck you really need to buy this oh damn
it's kind of convincing you that you
have acne when you have clear clear
complexion so there's all this working
it's not ethical it's not yeah
um and so with the with the software
that we're running
our our goal is to be ethical as far as
based on how you're performing with our
software this is where we've seen
students end up scoring with the MCAT
now my software or I should say my
software it's a cup it's Dr Huffman's
software mostly
um
aside from my software you know I work
with students all the time and they're
if they don't want to use adapt prep my
my biggest piece of advice to them is go
use aamc resources
um totally not sponsored by AMC but I'm
giving them a plug because they're the
ones writing the MCAT and they don't
really have any incentive to give you a
lower score than you're going to be
getting
now sometimes there are years where
students will say hey those practice
exams were a lot easier than the real
thing yeah yeah but you hear that less
than what you hear from these private
for-profit companies yeah so yeah very
very interesting we're all all the way
to the beginning of this last segment
when you said that the having this like
self-awareness of your own abilities
right and having a a did I say that yeah
Dan you make me sound good
that's what we do here help people
unleash themselves fully
um you're no you nailed it that that
having that that self-awareness of where
we uh need the most developmental
practice and then being able to leverage
software to help us both analyze
ourselves effectively to know where the
where we need to study and then helping
us actually do that studying to get
there it's so critical
I'm like my mind's going so many places
about about like you know being able to
even leverage tools like this for for
our ability to learn about whatever
subject we want is that you know
closed-loop feedback adaptive learning
for three-year-olds ten-year-olds 20
year olds well you know different
language apps I mean now we're going
into the field of creating apps which
maybe we should stay away from but
you're right though but it's all there
to you know to maximize our potential
you know there's there's a lot of
different angles we could take you know
there's there's philosophies out there
to say know your strengths and play work
with your strengths and in other
situations yeah work with your strengths
but also know where you're weaknesses
are because you don't want to be blind
to that no blind spots yeah no blind
spots and at the very least you can say
hey I'm not good at that exactly I'm
going to bring someone on my team who is
good at that yes yeah yes
yeah and the another interesting thing
that that you said was that you pointed
out is like this this super duper
importance with uh having an ethical
groundedness in the product so yeah
you're not absolutely you're not
purposely trying to mislead people uh to
thinking that they're scoring Less in
order to buy your product like that
sounds you know those days are over
those days of of this maximizing
shareholder value in this business as
usual with politicians that shit's over
we're so over that stuff we are totally
moving forth with more um ethical
inclusive equality of opportunity for
all people economic freedoms across the
world maximizing individual and
Collective potential we care about that
so much we talk about that a lot so and
there's I was gonna say there's a
there's a such a hurdle that we still
have to overcome right because in order
I mean even I'm not a business person by
training I kind of wish I took more
business classes and marketing classes
but alas nope your Instagram accounts
pretty good
I was
yeah
um and it's been fun to see how our
intern Felipe has has really taken the
Baton there yeah
good work because the links in the bio
over there that is really strong it's
really strong account we've got some
powerful quotes there it's like yeah
yeah but and and to go back to your
other point of
yeah we to to Market ethically at a
price you know exactly but to to keep
living as a company and grow yourself
and grow it yeah and and getting out
there and being known to people that's
what we think so that you can last I
think that's that same thing that's the
industry challenge artists and
entrepreneurs that are starting up they
said same thing it's like a huge
challenge yeah and doing it ethically
even though having tremendous patience
because it's better to be super patient
and do things ethically
um than exploiting and trying to run
really fast and then you'll just your
soul will be corrupted yeah yeah yeah
where you know the the expression used
to say nice guys we should gender
neutralize it right nice people finish
last yeah and my my hope with this is
that nice people or maybe we'll switch
it a little bit ethical people won't
finish last that yeah we've we're
hitting this point in culture and
Society where ethical nice people if you
will
are going to come to the Forefront yeah
yeah they'll be the people that
um help there there are in many ways the
ones that are opening this Overton
window to the possibilities of the most
ethical grounds possible and moving
other people to say look at how cool
this is if we progress completely
ethically together
um as one yeah and together together at
this point yeah there's like a
transition from survival of the fittest
to survival of the friendliest oh I like
that yeah
that would be good yeah yeah I'm glad
you take that one that's a good one that
we learned as well
okay couple quick power around thoughts
on the way out um we like to ask these
questions to our guests on the show okay
uh-oh uh do you think we're alone in the
cosmos oh man
you know that is a great question we
won't know until we know right
I mean if you're if you're in a room by
yourself
are you alone in that room oh
yeah what do you think if you well I
mean unless there's you're alone as far
as being alone as a human being
but what else is then there is there is
there an energy force around us what do
you think I I well see this is where I'm
gonna get in trouble with with the
people in my community and maybe even my
family but I I think there is this
energy force around us
that
we haven't been able to measure yeah
yeah I think that's a legit thing yeah
you know and
it's it's weird things like when my dad
passed away a couple years ago we
started seeing heart shapes and I never
would have like keyed into these kind of
things and so this is going to get like
really weird and maybe to sci-fi for you
not at all they're gonna talk about this
stuff all the time good deal good deal
and that stuff's like yeah
um
and so I was on a hike at one point I
was volunteering with my son's Boy Scout
Troop and and taking these kids on a
hike and I'm like oh this is something
my dad would love you know being out in
nature he would always take the dog for
a walk out in the trails where I grew up
so it really made me think of my dad and
no joke within seconds I looked down on
the ground and there's this heart shape
well it was an acorn split in half and
it left that heart shape
um yeah yeah so it's it's there's
there's something going on where maybe
there's some messaging my kids use it
against me though because we went to the
the Humane Society
um to look at potentially getting a cat
and there was this oh it was the ugliest
cat but it had hearts in its fur and
they're like grandpa says we have to get
this cat yeah like what but sure enough
there's hearts in the cat so I've got
another cat
you I ended up adopting that cat yeah we
did I doubt that cat even though you
know I couldn't bring myself to pet it
for like the first three weeks because
you could feel every vertebrae in its
back it was nasty but yeah whoa yes
that communication that energy force
kind of there's there's something out
there
when when we limit our
are are I guess what we what we
collectively believe to just what the
perceptions of this physical vehicle are
yeah that is limiting in so many ways
that we're not enabling ourselves to see
what exists beyond the perception of
this vehicle and there are people that
have been training the muscles of
perceiving past the three-dimensional
reality that are really good at that
yeah and whatever exists out there is
exciting I'm glad that you have had
experiences in that um and so yeah
that's why we asked yeah do you think
this is a simulation
oh like that what is that one show that
movie where it's like cameras and
everybody's just it is The Truman Show
right is that the kind of simulation
you're asking about but there's a lot of
different ways to take this question I
was gonna say is this where like the
behind the scenes people come out that
have been following my life and say
surprise guys this has been all just
about you jerks you know who wrote the
script during this year to this year
[Laughter]
oh man
have you ever watched Battlestar
Galactica yeah yeah so that kind of that
things are on repeat
sometimes like I would buy into that
yeah are we going to be on repeat until
we actually do a good job of what we're
supposed to do as a human race yeah
totally yeah totally yeah that that's
that's an option that you know this
between the spark of life and the spark
of death that what exists on the other
side of that is maybe just the cycle of
potentially reincarnation into different
planets orbiting stars or the same one
or recycling back into the same one
there's a lot of people that would get
it mad at me for saying that but we're
saying potentials potentially yeah I
mean you look at laws of thermodynamics
right energy can neither be created nor
destroyed
and I'd like to think I have energy more
so on some days than others but if my
energy can either be created nor
destroyed when my physical body dies
what happens to my energy yeah
potentially just buried into the I don't
know the dirt maybe potentially and then
you grow trees that have fruits Etc in
that sense my energy transfers into a
different form true and it may not need
to be like the soul that transfers but
it treats it transfers the tree
um and last question is what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world
I get to choose how there's some my
mind's like buzzing on that one my my
first my first thing that I went to
is more maybe it was because I watched
that empathy video that shout out to
David Savage yeah yeah yeah was it 131
or something yes anyways we've had them
twice on the show okay yeah but in my
life I would say empathy has been huge
yeah and so there's a beauty in
beautiful empathy yeah you know and and
maybe it goes back to the MCAT stuff too
yeah of empathizing with individuals
I promise you I didn't plan this this
isn't scripted but this is where my
mind's going
um
empathy with individuals who want to
become medical professionals
and and having that empathy for them and
maybe you know being able to connect
with those people I think that's that's
pretty beautiful yeah like seeing people
where they're at and what they're
feeling and coming alongside with them
so it's not really a visual Beauty thing
it's it's more of a an emotional I agree
with you totally agree with you on that
one that's such a powerful one knowing
how to get behind the eyes of another
completely in a genuine loving caring
way and then it also doesn't surprise me
that you pick that because you yourself
are professing all the time so you're
trying to help students gain you're
trying to empathize with them at their
level to help them gain the augmentation
of perception and then also with the
Physicians not only about meeting them
where they're at so they can learn to
become a physician but also it's
learning for them to empathize with
their patients so that the patients them
to learn empathy too that would be a
good MCAT section are you empathetic
that's what we're saying earlier I think
we may be moving to potentially move
into that yeah this has been such a
pleasure Elizabeth thank you thank you
this wasn't as scary as I thought it
would be see boom there we go this was
fun actually I was kind of nervous about
this I'm not gonna lie
um but no this was good good thank you
for asking great questions may we may we
ask you like what was like what was the
thing that was like making you nervous
and then what ended up being this
experience that made it not nervous for
you yeah you know oh man people watching
it might think wow she's just insecure I
think there's there's always this humble
insecurity in me of
do I have anything worth saying like is
there going to be value in what I'm
transferring
so I think the fear is always there of I
want there to be value in what I'm
transferring does that make sense yeah
totally yeah yeah yeah so what made it
okay you know it's kind of some mental
speak you know that inner coach in my
head of you can do this let's go you
want just just be yourself
um go with what you know yeah and yeah
good so it was it was good good I'm glad
that yeah good I'm and that's a really
important moment for for others to
hopefully take from this as experience
as that you gain this sort of you know
everyone sort of has that that feeling
yeah what's imposter syndrome right yeah
yeah that and then and then being able
to go through the process of of of
learning how to crush it like learning
how to be confident in your own shoes
and disseminate your wisdoms to to other
people in the world
and then just making it really clear
from you know on my end as well for for
those interested is that you know we're
talking about you know empathy being so
important is that you know when you're
always trying to relate to the person
that is nervous that is that is you know
showing them that you love them and care
about them that you generally want them
to succeed and that I'm here to to help
you Unleash Your Soul to the fullest of
the world and that is my role and so you
know when that from even messaging to
first meeting to talking to everything
until now that that is that is the
that's the flow of things from my end to
the individuals that we get the pleasure
to sit down with so that's awesome and
it was real yeah you know because
sometimes you have people that they've
got an agenda and they check off the
list yeah but this this was it yeah
thank you it was real thank you I
appreciate it you're real you're awesome
I try there's nothing else I can be this
is yeah this has been such a pleasure
thank you for coming onto the show
thanks for teaching us about mastering
the MCAT there's so much Nuance here go
check got the links below everyone
um check out the dev prep link below and
go explore it share it with other people
for 200 bucks get a really robust way to
to train yourself to for the on the MCAT
and share it with other people around
the US and Canada and even around the
world so that people around the world
can learn about what it's actually
potentially like to do an Adaptive MCAT
training process and bring that to other
places and shout out to all you for
tuning in we really appreciate it give
us your thoughts in the comments below
we'd love to hear from you also go and
build the future manifest your destiny
into the world everyone we love you
let's rebirth the public intellectual
together Inspire the Next Generation to
build the future much love we will see
you soon
peace
awesome yay yay that was cool that's it
yeah yeah